dans le cortège au côté des
Moon oui qui garde un peu d'humour parce
qu'il guide les photographes pour éviter
que tout le monde tombe c'est un moment
sérieux monsieur ellissoun pour vous
c'était important d'être présent
aujourd'hui apparemment c'est pas
sérieux il y a des gens qui font des
selfies avec moi oui c'est un moment
sérieux mais on peut on peut avoir le
sourire quand même surtout quand on voit
qu'il y a autant de monde donc c'est
génial justement c'est vrai que c'est
difficile quand on est dans une
manifestation de s'apercevoir mais là
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de monde ça vous rassure ouais c'est
très rassurant franchement puis je vois
pas je vois pas que des Juifs vous êtes
pas juif monsieur bah voilà donc c'est
parfait non non donc c'est très bien
c'est chouite qu'il ait pas que des
Juifs il fallait que ce ne soit pas que
la communauté juive qui soit en soutien
mais tous les Français mais oui oui tous
les Français enfin la plupart des
Français je sais pas combien on est mais
je pense qu'on est beaucoup et ça c'est
chouette ça ça me réchauffe le cœur il y
a eu des polémique politique alors je
sais pas si vous les avez suivis
monsieur Semoun mais qu'avez-vous pensé
de ceux qui disaient oui mais je
manifeste mais pas forcément à côté du
Ren qui voulait oua je trouve ça idiot
je trouve ça complètement idiot le Ren
ils font ce qu'ils veulent c'est un bon
prétexte pour pas défiler en fait je
pense donc ouais c'est pas terrible vous
êtes une personnalité connue reconnue
c'est important on a vu plusieurs
personnalités du monde du spectacle
c'est important comme moi oui oui c'est
chouette parce que pour certaines
personnes en toute modestie on
représente peut-être quelque chose donc
peut-être que notre voix peut porter
donc honnêtement pas si ça va changer
grandchose au racisme ambiant à
l'antisémitisme ambiant mais c'est mieux
que rien merci beaucoup
merci de nous avoir accorder cette
interview